Tomica did you sell the first screenplay
that's your bros i did and i would use
sell loosely okay um it's called jar by
the door and like I was really really
grateful that I was validated right away
most screenwriters don't really get that
validation they have to sort of get it
from their family or their friends or a
teacher or someone but that kind of
validation came really quickly for me I
am I want a contest and it was like
$10,000 and I helped move me to LA and I
optioned the script two or three times
so it was kind of keeping me alive you
know it's like $5,000 for each option
which was a lot of eight years ago and
so that was amazing and then I actually
sold the script in quotes
I sold the script for six figures and
yeah there's no other way to point it
wasn't good it's like the cheque was a
rubber jack and it was really it was
kind of devastating because I had worked
with these people for about three or
four years they had literally optioned
the script twice with two or three times
before and so I probably already made
about 15 to 20 grand from this company
so of course there was no reason for us
to think right that this cheque wouldn't
be good and so we got the cheque my
manager was like okay just hold on it
to it for a day or two you know it's
just just to be sure about LA they said
hold on it they want to make sure the
money is in there and then a day became
a week and then a week became two weeks
and I was like well what's going on and
he's like I'm not sure but I'm not sure
if that check is gonna clear they're
having some issues with their finance
year or whatever and I was like oh my
god you're kidding me of course I had
already spent this money in my mind and
it was the perfect scenario I was gonna
get to direct it I was gonna to producer
credit it was gonna change man it just
never it just never cleared and I
thought that you know if someone asked
me today if they'd say well would you
change that I would say no because it
sort of pushed me into a whole other
amazing thing that I create
so after that I just did a lot of
soul-searching and I thought well is
this what is it this all I'm supposed to
be doing with my life trying to sell my
script trying to do this there's got to
be more to it so I started to mentor and
teach and I totally fell in love with
demystifying the filmmaking process for
kids and so someone asked me if you
could do anything what would you do
and I said aside from filmmaking I grant
wishes
to the kids in the make-a-wish
Foundation because I really admired that
organization so I'll add hey maybe I can
combine these two things and I created
make a film Foundation which grants film
wishes to kids who have serious or
life-threatening medical conditions and
this never would have happened if I
hadn't you know if that check wasn't bad
and I cashed that check I would have had
a whole different color to my career but
I mean I've done so much and created so
many films with these kids and I mean
it's just I wouldn't change it so I mean
I just wouldn't change it so it was just
a lesson and this is what you think you
want and every you know just because it
seems like it's a bad thing
it doesn't necessarily mean that it is
it maybe it's just sending it in another
direction that your that is really your
true calling and what you're meant to do
oh no how long did you feel bad for and
when did the idea pop in how long did
that let's see so that happened right
around 2000 I felt bad for about I'd say
about a year year and a half and then I
actually I was doing some self
empowerment self awareness program
called land markers and usually asked
yeah yes and and they actually gave me
some really incredible tools to it just
sort of helped me to redefine what
possibility is and redefine what I was
able to create at any moment in my life
and so and then they had this class
where you create a project and I thought
this would be the perfect class to kind
of create this this project out of and
so that's kind of how that evolved and
and it just it changed my life it
changed my world and it changed a lot of
my perspective I mean even to this day
creating make a film foundation even
like right now today it has affected
what I'm doing I I just got a job
another job that I love if I hadn't
created make a film foundation I would
not have the skills and everything else
for this job that I'm doing right now
nice how much do you think having that
like down time because you know how a
lot of especially no get yourself back
up there and dust yourself off and don't
feel bad this is Hollywood but sometimes
I think people need that like down
period and if you have to go there and
feel bad I think it's like you should
allow yourself do you think that that
really helped spark that idea yeah I
think it's very important for you to
allow yourself to feel how you need to
feel I think you should put an
expiration date on it right even if you
have to do it a little bit every day ok
I've got 15 minutes to think about what
happened and then I'm gonna do something
creative and amazing right that supports
who I really am I don't live there right
yeah so it's like you can have the
feelings but not let the feelings have
you right and I think it's important
because a lot of the times those
feelings are what inspire or spawn some
of our most creative work I mean our
characters go through stuff and we want
to see that I mean how are you gonna
really authentically right about that or
portray that if you don't allow yourself
to experience it as well and it done me
you know let's look at Elena's more as
that screaming crying Canadian girl yeah
like but it was like a heartbreak that
maybe that really blew her career up
right and she allowed herself did she
just poured all that stuff into her
creative music and and gave it to the
world and I think sometimes we have to
do that can we go back for a moment to
jar by the door and you started writing
it I think you showed it to some family
members yes I showed it to my brother
and he was like no you have to
yourself and I did and then he gave me
some feedback and I implemented all of
his notes even though they were prickly
but I still I implemented all of his
notes and he read it again he like was
like thumbs up he loved it but then I
didn't really know what to do with it so
he was like well why don't you just try
submitting it to you know some places
you know there wasn't really the whole
go online type of thing happening at the
same level as it is now what year was it
was 90 al was yeah it was absolutely
dial-up right so that's what we were
doing and so I just did some research
and I found out about like the Sundance
screenwriting lab and I submitted it to
a few contests like the Nichols
fellowship and I've got like incredible
feedback right it was really great I was
a finalist for Sundance this is like
right off the bat I didn't even know
what Sundance was I I did this stuff in
a way that was so naive it's like I was
just doing it I didn't know anything I
would like send stuff out to Hollywood I
had no agent no manager I didn't even
know what that stuff was or how you get
one or even that I needed one I would
just blindly you know how they say now
no we don't accept unsolicited material
all that I would just send stuff it's
not about but it actually worked for me
I ended up getting incredible responses
and feedback and I started setting up
meetings after like I did win one of
those contests and when the Gordon Parks
Independent Film Award and it had like
this huge prize like ten thousand
dollars and I used that to eventually to
move to LA but because I had made all
these connections just completely out of
the blue because I didn't know any
better I had made all these connections
I would write to be this oh my god yes
we were tight I would type the letters
like a word processor oh why it's
electrons yeah
and then I'll send the letters out and
so I get I like I have actual real
letters of like responses from people
and you know of course there's the the
big huge pile of rejection letters but I
actually had a pretty significant pile
of letters where people responded to me
and it was weird I'm like when I think
about it now I'm like oh my back then it
was really kind of you know I thought
that's how you did it you did it
yourself and so I would say getting back
to that actually to a certain degree
it's kind of where my head is and what I
would say to screenwriters it's like
even though you get a manager and it or
something like that you still have to be
in control of your career you still have
to do stuff Network meet people and all
that kind of stuff because you're
literally laying a foundation that is
gonna pay off I had you know I've had
meetings with people from those blind
letters that I queries that I sent out
after I won the Gordon Parks and I had
was like a finalist and Sundance I mean
I could put something in the letters
like oh my script was a Sundance
finalist or whatever but I didn't have
much more it was the only script I had
written you know but um it was something
and so these people would meet with me
so when I came out to LA I had like 10
or 15 meetings set up with people just
from just you know I didn't know anybody
manager no agent nothing yeah and so do
you tribute that to well know it what do
you tribute to that - aside from talent
well what what else because of do you
think because you weren't afraid you
just were like I'm gonna do this I think
a lot of people overthink it know that I
wasn't supposed to do it right so it's
like because I didn't know any better I
probably just bumbled my way into some
success you know I was but you know what
let's let's take that back to what you
said I wasn't afraid because I didn't
know that I should be afraid so it's
completely connected to what you just
said if I had known that you're not
supposed to do it that way right then I
wouldn't have but I didn't know you know
I didn't know that you supposed to have
a man
and you can't submit unsolicited
material and this and that and I just
didn't know I just did it because I
didn't have any other way I didn't know
how else are you gonna do it you just
look in that big book the Hollywood
that's what it was remember the
Hollywood creative directory you guys
remember that it's a big old thick book
they it's online now okay but it was
like $65 and it literally listed all the
managers producers the production
companies so someone gave me a tip I
don't remember who and they were like
you should get this book and you should
just send your letters out to any
production company or producers your
managers in here so that's what I did I
just went through it and I looked and
see you know okay who likes is there
anybody here who does any kind of
diverse material or is there anybody
here who does like ensemble indi work
you know that kind of stuff so I ended
up sending it to places like the
shooting gallery
remember the gallery that was Slingblade
back in the day okay do you remember uh
Billy Bob Thornton's oh yeah absolutely
yeah I think they were he was discovered
through the shooting gallery and so
there's like these little beckon ah I
wish you had booked now but they had all
these little baby independent companies
that would do really great stuff you
know I guess they went bankrupt they
would do it again yeah I really see
stuff right that was that was a great
film but think about today so 2016 if
you were still in that same spot because
you were still back on the East Coast at
that time what would you do knowing that
now you can look anybody up by just
doing a google search for the most part
or getting IMDB Pro and and and knowing
that it's so saturated but you still
have a spurning desire you still have
talent right would you do so
do you mean what would I do if I had
written this for it yeah to get it out
and you wanted to come to LA and set up
meetings I think because I know so many
people who are in the business and so I
guess it would be
is it me now knowing the people that I
know or is it me then
anyone you know because that's a
different cuz I would just
there's actors that I know there's
writers producers I would get and maybe
I'd do it the same way anyway whether I
knew them or not I just find someone who
did it and or who was in some way in the
business and just asked their advice
what do you think I should do
is there someone can you recommend
someone to to read it or I I also
probably cuz I did this back then again
cuz I didn't know any better but I still
do this now I would create my own
readings so I had a lot of friends
anyway you know cuz New York was like
that nots LA is kind of like that but
New York it's a different kind of I
don't want to say Posse but friendship
pool like I respected the temple and so
when you do a reading or something like
that you get people to come to your
reading and it's like a party and that
kind of thing and I did a little bit of
that out here trying to establish that
same dynamic but that really yielded a
lot of results when you literally just
do a reading of your work people come
they see it they they're like wow that
was great and then those people talk to
people they know and it just sort of as
a snowball effect so I would say always
if you're writing or anything like that
you still are in control of putting your
stuff out there in some way shape or
form and it doesn't have to cost a lot
of money it doesn't have to cost
anything so you say almost do like hey
let's have a wine and cheese in my place
and come and read yes my scripts I take
it a step further like and I wrote a
script with my best friend sort of like
a kind of a roadtrip girly movie
whatever it was really funny right so we
got some of the people that we knew we
told everybody we're going to do this
reading we cooked like we cooked like
real food and we're like it's gonna be
food and drink and we sort of supplied
everything and it was like packed it was
like literally 150 200 people because
and then we started like making that a
thing so people would want and you know
of course yourself has to be at least
interesting
so it would be those two things and so
the people would come in to be like a
big party you'd meet people you'd have
fun the work is cool you can talk about
that and then literally we'd have to
kick people out you know or we'd have it
at a theater and they'd be like me you
guys have to you know because there's
food there's wine there's creative stuff
happening and in LA especially we have
to create these things for ourself
because it's not as easy to do as it is
in New York here people are all over the
place and creating a creative group is
like it's not just like a creative thing
that you need to feed yourself
creatively it's spiritual you know it's
like a spiritual food and you know
fellowship it's like all of that
happening at once and people will come
to experience that you know
you